[Music]
all right Abby I got to talk about this
drama coming up on Dance Moms a ghost
from the past reappears I'm not speaking
about the dose it's up if he asked him
about he's gonna go she said to us tell
me why you're here um i've been thinking
about competing again when you started
this did you think seven seasons we'd be
doing this would be a studio in LA I
never thought anyone would watch the
first six episodes I thought this is the
dumbest thing I've ever seen we keep
pushing the envelope we keep working and
mothers keep screaming and they won't
shut up while I'm teaching and it just
goes but it's my life I don't know how
long I'll be there so we'll see the
dance mom star is currently awaiting his
sentencing in a bankruptcy fraud case
she could face up to 10 years in prison
what your mental state how are you
feeling uh I'm good I try to stay
positive and happy and I know I made
some mistakes along the way but I've
pledged all those and let's let's go and
you know maybe I needed few months
vacation I don't know I wanna get light
of it I don't want to be funny about
it's very serious but there's a lot of
strange unanswered questions so
eventually I think everything will come
out and it'd all be good